sarajevo's Olympic ski resort with
nothing to ski on
Spanish sunbathing on the 11th day of
Christmas these are the dog days of a
winter warm spell January temperature
records are not just being broken but
incinerated across Europe yeah it's like
nice weather for Viking but we know it's
like the planet is burning so these
January records come after a year when
England registered 40 degrees Celsius
for the first time ever in fact 2022 was
the hottest year in record here in the
UK in France and in Spain climate change
is making these extremes more frequent
and making heatwise more intense
Europe's Rising mercury has caused a
fall in demand for natural gas EU
storage levels are high after countries
stocked up in the wake of the invasion
of Ukraine it's easing immediate fears
over how Europe can wean itself off
Russian gas that trade did drop sharply
last year and then the nordstream one
pipeline was taken out by Apparent
sabotage also there are fears the
Kremlin could fully cut Supply at any
time it takes a while to completely
transition an energy
and uh to do that they're going to have
to keep working at the pace they are if
not accelerated my concern is that a
warmer winter which is giving some
some breathing space is going to lead to
a warmer summer
Professor Grant walk says Russia's
Invasion has spurred Europe to speed up
its transition away from fossil fuels in
the interim Europe is buying liquefied
natural gas from the U.S and Qatar as
this winter is far from over if there is
a shutdown of the pipelines by by Russia
that again could contribute to some to
some issues in terms of Supply
Europe's warmer weather may have just
delayed its energy headache until next
winter Redmond Shannon Global News
London